encore quelques étiquettes accrochées
avant le grand départ des soldes d'hiver
la course à la réduction commence
mercredi et dans les magasins s'organise
on était en vente privée avec déjà des
pourcentages de remise
hélas les soldes officiels demain on
rajoute des nouvelles décotes et on
change certaine décote dans cette
enseigne de prêt-à-porter le rayonnage a
été retravaillé pour l'occasion les
vêtements sont rangés par taille pour
que le client puisse mieux se retrouver
moins de stock à écouler pour cette
petite bijouterie mais quelques soldes
quand même pour se faire plaisir
nous avons également des petites
pastilles qui sont dans nos vitrines qui
permettent à nos clientes de reconnaître
en fonction des couleurs dès pastilles
des différentes réductions que nous
allons avoir sur les différents bijoux
avec les fêtes de fin d'année les soldes
d'hiver sont
les plus gros rendez vous de l'année
pour les commerçants c'est le moment de
l'année où ils vont se dés stockées en
proposant des promotions très des
réductions très agressive de moins 30 à
moins 50 sur la première démarque pour
effectivement ce déstocker et faire
entrer ensuite la nouvelle collection
qui 9 janvier au 19 février c'est tout
le centre commercial qui se mobilisent
des renforts en sécurité en nettoyage
accompagne la fluence supplémentaire
pour se reposer dans ce marathon des
bonnes affaires le centre propose à ses
clients un espace détente et même une
bulle cocooning pour le premier mercredi
et samedi
donc on a toutes les soldes ici donc
interne au magasin
et ensuite effectivement il y aura deux
stands qui seront mobilisées sur la
place centrale donc avec deux personnes
qui seront qui sont déconseillés
esthéticienne qui vont proposer ses
prestations pour les clientes
sur les premiers jours des soldes le
centre commercial parly 2 enregistre une
progression de 30 à 35% de nombre de ses
clients